to start this first period brought to you by
Toyota great to have you with us on a Tuesday
night in Chicago closing in on Christmas Devon
Taves with a pass to Nathan McKinnon and a shot
into traffic lovely pass for Miles wood and wood
hums one high long rebound to Ross Colton Colton
behind the net now it's drewan and the Stick
of Donado breaks up the stuff attempt miles
wood dropped a glove not in a fighting G look
like Dominic H coming out of the net like that
great play by moric and things still pretty
open on the ice right now for molinsky a save
by moric rebound to Dickinson Donado up at
neutral to his right drwan with a physical
play into the glove of Felino Hawks control
at Center Felino over the line dropped off
Dickinson to Donado and a kick save by gorev
valer nushin shadowed by Colin Blackwell and
McKinnon back to retrieve the puck at center
it's Manson now for ranin moo ransing it in
the middle and the save made by moric and uh
I love the French cops and boy even as a Young
Man Rocky wordss had dress shirts with cuff
Lings Conor badar knocks the puck back into
the Hawks attacking Zone from the goal line
all the way across to Z no rebound score Ryan
Donado was right on the doorstep and the box
grab a one- nothing lead Conor Bard in the
vision that he had once his Puck get into the
offensive zone right here you see Donado he has
been knocking on the door bad turnover there
by the defenseman but a good pick off by Bard
who finds the weak side defenseman zit he P it
right off the post right there and look who's
on the doorstep and he has been greasy for the
last few games there he's getting chances like
you read about and Donado Cashes in with Kish of
out sick he slides into that right right spot and
Reichel going hard to the paint and look at that
re re action forado Devon Taves the defenseman on
the ice McKinnon back to Taves McKinnon watch
him snap this Puck around drwan below the goal
line to McKinnon nushin in the slot drwan for
NuSkin Colorado scores on the power play it's
tied at one well they can make something out of
nothing rather quickly NuSkin again I mean he's
he's been terrific for the for the Avalanche
he he's been an engine he's been driving it and
there he is the high slot you can see right there
he was actually looked like he was going to go in
closer and I think he looked to his left if you
can see to your left you're going to see ranton
slide in there as well big Number 96 when Ranon
does that and you can see NuSkin looks up right
here and now he's going to go forward oh stops
and he puts on the brakes and gets that right
on the tape that goes right under the Stick of
Kaiser radish is taking the weak side man ran but
the stick handling curling now a cross broken up
by Colin Blackwell Puck loose and Ranon and over
to the the wall to grab it boy had the puck right
on his sticker just exploded on him a Kinnon into
the crease and nushin denied by moric Blackwell to
clear hey welcome back to the lineup for Blackwell
I mean what a position to be in this is Colin
Blackwell's first game in the NHL since February
27 amazing that's a long that's an awful long
time I went through a very similar period that
I didn't play coming back with something else 10
months a long time Jonathan drewan knocked Away by
Crevier loose puck ranted in off the side of the
net up to drewan 30 seconds to go on the power
play Granton in McKinnon a one-time back around
the wall and that's actually Ross Colton on the
far side Circle kusin a couple brilliant Saves
by mazic but the puck eventually flips to the
back of the net Colorado scores it's another
goal on the power play for valer nushin what
more can he do that was an unbel un believable
first save I couldn't believe he kept it out
of the net side to side and post to post and
using your edges but here's the setup in Theus
in front of that this is the first one missed by
McKinnon on a on a real good seam pass there by
Randon and and look at NuSkin right there he
gets inside position uh Crevier kind of went
to the outside right there at first he looked
like he was inside then he faded away a little
bit and Kaiser look at two young defenseman just
trying to get in there on the inside but NuSkin
wins the battle the pass ahead of Ben Myers
playing in his fourth game of the season with
the ad Bowen Byam for Manson top of the circle
Manson shoots knocked away and Anthony boiler
on the feet from Taylor radish still in his own
Zone back to the defenseman Philip Roose well
those two power plays against have really taken
taken away some of that momentum and that some of
that jump now it's about getting back to five on
five simplifying the game again there a good start
to the game here by the Hawks scoring the first
goal of the game Conor Bard here he goes Reichel
scores oh boy does that feel good for Lucas
Reichel and it's a two2 game what a pass this
is on the right side of the ice it looked like
Bard was going to shoot it he's got his head up
the whole way everyone goes towards Bard cuz he's
the most dangerous shooter of the two here but he
slides it over to the left-handed reel and ases
he put it right on the plate and perfect shot
by Lucas Reichel firing this one here the eyes of
bad looking up the whole way and a terrific finish
there from Lucas Reichel that's reel's third good
reverse hit by Philip Bru Ryan Donado chops at the
puck but now it's Bruce on the second try all
the way up to Conor Bard Bard knocked Away by
gorv waxs it down low M rans it in there
shoveled up to the line and held by Isaac
Phillips and that one gets on net Phillips
again just inside the line into traffic it's
lurking it's in the crease it did not cross
the goal line the glass right there right to
the right of gorv and it's going to come
by right here good play by Isaac Phillips
to let this one rip goes off the left
pad off the post and just hangs there
before bym can kind of yank that out
of Harm's Way oh boy this is a game of
inches Jor has no idea where that puck is none
whatsoever Ranson and plays the Puck around
Philip Bruce in a two-on-one with NuSkin ran
it in off the glass behind the net long rebound
pocketed by R reel for Bard just wide by Reichel
to get into a better scoring position now Cole
Gutman the former University of Denver Pioneer
oh hell his buddies are watching this one back
there Gutman across Phillips off the back side of
the net and Ryan Donado is there for the rebound
score zeit still got an assist lose Bard for
Reichel blocker save gorv wood wood drops it
off for drewan and McKenzie an whistle jumps
the route it's ree Johnson Conor Bard save
gorv fourth liners grinding away for Colorado
right now yeah they're doing a great job they
the Hawks have been on the ice as a group for a
minute 28 seconds now that is a long and healthy
shift three minutes in into the period and keny
Roda shut down by moric over totally out of gas
a minute and 43 seconds hemmed in stops and
starts reaching and lunging and that's a great
save by morzac right there on kib Ron and that's
a great shift by that fourth line of the Colorado
Avalanche man Jared bner has got to be thrilled
with that one and now he just what's he toss out
after that for moric Blackhawks without two key
defenseman tonight Seth Jones and Kevin kinsky
they're typically quarterback think great to see
Kevin kinsky back here at Chicago amongst the
brothers as Nick Felino says Zev Pino score Tyler
Johnson on the back door and the Hawks lead in the
third what a pass good things happen but it
all happens on the breakout Berard gains The
Zone rate here stops on a dime a little
backand pass two Avalanche go to him zit
makes a good play to his left left play goes
from bino to the right but it all starts with
a good entry into the zone right there and
a good chip in play by Tyler Johnson watch
the angle of his stick right there he knows
he's got to get it over the glove over the
pad and he does just that playing with
an empty net 6 seconds left McKinnon on
the puck McKinnon pulls up NuSkin a shot by
Taves it wouldn't have counted Hax win 3 to2